the longest day of the year in juneau
alaska is june 21st it's
1096.5 minutes long
half a year later when the days are at
their shortest the days are about
382.5 minutes long
if it's not a leap year the year is 365
days long and june 21st is the 172nd day
of the year
write a trigonometric function that
models the length l of the teeth day of
the year so it's going to be l as a
function of t
assuming it's not a leap year so i
encourage you to pause this video and
try to do this on your own before i try
to work through it
so let me give a go at it so instead of
first starting at l of t i'm going to
actually start with l as a function of u
where u is another variable i'll just
use this kind of an intermediary an
intermediate intermediary variable
that'll help set it up in a little bit
of a simpler way
where
you
is days
days after
days after june
june
21st so let's just think about this a
little bit june 21st
june 21st
if we're thinking about in terms of u
u is going to be equal to zero because
it's zero days after june 21st but if
we're thinking about in terms of t
june 21st is the 172nd day of the year
it's
172. so what's the relationship between
u and t
well it's shifted by 172 days
u
is going to be equal to
t
t
minus 172.
notice when t is 172 when t is 172 u is
equal to 0. so let's figure out l of u
first and then later we can just
substitute u with t minus 172
so first of all what's happening when u
is equal to zero let me write all this
down so what is happening when u is
equal to zero well u equals zero is june
21st and that's the maximum point so
what trig function hits its maximum
point when the input into the trig
function is zero
well sine of zero is zero while cosine
of zero is one cosine hits its maximum
point
so i'd like to it seems a little bit
easier to model this with a cosine
so it's going to be some amplitude
some amplitude
times cosine
times cosine of
of and let's say
i'll write some coefficient
c right over here actually let me just
use a b since i already used an a
some coefficient over here times r u
times our u
plus
some constant that'll shift the entire
function up
up or down so this is the form that our
function of u is going to take and now
we just have to figure out what each of
these parts are
so first let's think about the amplitude
and what the midline is going to be the
midline is essentially how much we're
shifting
the the function up
so let's get our calculator out
so the midline is going to be halfway
between these two numbers so we could
say
1096
point
plus
382.5
divided by 2
divided by 2 gets us to 739.5
so that's what c is equal to
c is equal to 739.5
now the amplitude is how much do we vary
from that midline so we could take 1096
minus this or we could take this minus
382.5
so let's do that so let's take 1096.5
minus what we just typed what we just
got 739.75
739.5
and we get
357 so this is how much we vary from
that midline so a is equal to 357.
so this right over here is equal to 357.
so what's b going to be equal to
and for that i always think about well
what's the behavior of the function
what's the period of the function going
to be
let me make a little table here so
so when
when you let's put some different inputs
from u from u when u is 0
we're zero days after june 21st we're at
our maximum point and we already said
that what we want what we want the
cosine function to evaluate to at that
point is essentially we want it to
evaluate as 357
times cosine
cosine of 0
plus
739.5
now what happens what's a full period
well a full period is a year at a year
we get to the same point in the year
which is i guess a little bit of common
sense so you go all the way to 365
you go all the way to when u is 365 we
should have completed a period we should
be back to that maximum point
so this should essentially be 357
times cosine
times cosine of 2 pi when do we when do
we if we were just thinking in terms of
a traditional trig function if we just
had a you know just a theta in here you
complete a period every 2 pi so this
should be equivalent to what i'm writing
out right over here
plus
739.5
so one way to think about it is b times
365
should be equal to 2 pi notice this is
going to be b times 365 so let's write
that down
b
times 365
times 365 that's the input into the
cosine function needs to be equal to 2
pi
or b is equal to 2 pi over 365
b
is equal to 2 pi
over 365
and we are almost done we figured out
what a b and c are now we just have to
substitute u with t minus 172 to get our
function of t so let's just do that so
we get we deserve a little bit of a drum
roll now l of t
is equal to
is equal to a which is 357
357
times cosine
of
b
2 pi over 365
2 pi
over 365
times not u but now we're going to write
in terms of t we want to think about day
of the year not days after june 21st so
times
t
minus 172
and then finally plus our midline
plus
739.5
and
we
are
done so it seems like a very complicated
expression but if you just break it down
and kind of think about it make the
point that we're talking about the
extreme point either the minimum or the
maximum make that something make that
when the input into our function is zero
or two pi right zero is actually the
easiest one and then later you can worry
about the shift
hopefully that you found that helpful